[Music]
in 1908 president Teddy Roosevelt wanted
to declare the Grand Canyon off limits
to all Timber and Mining operations it
would take another 11 years for Congress
to designate the Grand Canyon a national
park sensing a final opportunity for
adventure Explorer GE Kincaid took a
boat down the Colorado River and Through
the Grand Canyon the canyon was rich in
minerals like gold silver and copper and
Kincaid wanted to see what he could find
before the area was closed off for good
about 40 miles up River from the El
Tovar Crystal Canyon Kincaid saw stains
in the sediment formation about 2 000
feet up he tied off the boat and got out
to investigate Kincaid couldn't find a
trail but after a short hike he found
something interesting covered in desert
brush steps hundreds of them carved in
Sandstone steps that wound their way up
to a high shelf on the side of the
canyon he followed the steps until he
came across a cavern entrance an
entrance that was clearly man-made
Kincaid entered the cavern and turned on
his flashlight on the walls he saw
writing but it wasn't English or Native
American writing it was Ancient Egyptian
Hieroglyphics Kincaid lifted his
flashlight and saw that the tunnel ran
far into the distance he didn't realize
it at the time but this was only the
beginning
[Music]
when GE Kincaid tied off his small
wooden boat to investigate the strange
coloration of the rock wall he was
hoping to find clues that would lead him
to a mineral deposit he wasn't expecting
to find hieroglyphics when Kincaid
noticed chisel marks in the walls he
drew his pistol turned on another light
and slowly walked deeper into the Gloom
he kept detailed notes of everything he
saw the main passageway is about 12 feet
wide now we're into nine feet toward the
farther end about 57 feet from the
entrance the first side passages Branch
off to the right and left along which on
both sides or a number of rooms about
the size of ordinary living rooms of
today though some are 30 by 40 feet
square these are entered by oval shaped
doors and are ventilated by round air
spaces through the walls into the
passages the walls are about three feet
six inches in thickness the passages are
chiseled or hewn as straight as could be
laid out by an engineer the ceilings of
many of the rooms converge to a center
the side passages near the entrance run
at a sharp angle from the main hall but
toward the rear they gradually reach a
right angle in Direction GE Kincaid now
realized he was in a huge complex he
estimated that as many as 50 000 people
could have lived here in some rooms he
found granaries with shelves of glazed
Pottery many of which still contain
seeds he found cooking areas and a huge
dining hall the rooms were full of
ancient artifacts Kincaid carefully
wrapped a few small metal and ceramic
objects for a later study another large
room Kincaid described as an area for
metal work a technology that should not
have existed in this area here are found
tools of all descriptions made of copper
these people undoubtedly knew the Lost
Art of hardening this medal which has
been sought by chemicals for centuries
without result on a bench running around
a work room with some charcoal and other
material properly used in the process
there's also slag and stuff similar to
Matt showing that these ancients smelted
oars but so far no trace of where or how
this was is done has been discovered nor
the origin of the ore GE Kincaid
explored the underground complex for
several hours still having no idea when
this place was used what it was used for
or who the builders were then he came
across another large room a crypt the
Crypt had shelf upon shelf and row upon
row of mummies dozens of them at this
point GE Kincaid realized that if he was
going to explore this entire underground
city he was going to need help
[Music]
GE Kincaid sent a few artifacts to the
Smithsonian along with his notes of what
he found he requested financial and
logistical support for what he felt was
the most significant archaeological
Discovery ever made the Smithsonian
agreed a few weeks later Professor S.A
Jordan arrived with a team of about 40
scientists researchers and laborers to
excavate and explore the ancient
underground city now with more lights
and Manpower the scientists realized
that the cave system layout wasn't
random it was a symmetrical deliberate
design the tunnels all led to a central
chamber in the chamber was a large
statue of what Kincaid thought looked
like Buddha like butter Buddha what'd I
say
over a hundred feet from the entrance is
the cross Hall several hundred feet long
and which are found the idle or image of
the people's God sitting cross-legged
with a lotus flower or lily in each hand
the cast of this face is Oriental and
the carving this Cavern the idol almost
resembles Buddha though the scientists
are not certain as to what religious
worship it represents taking into
consideration everything found thus far
it is possible that this worship most
resembles the ancient people of Tibet no
I didn't think we were allowed to say
Oriental are we bringing it back uh
we're not this was written over a
hundred years ago oh right when we had
freedom of speech no Oriental in this
context just means Eastern
because of this discovery Kincaid's team
started calling the complex The Citadel
the Crypt was one of the bigger rooms
discovered now with enough light Kincaid
was able to fully describe what he saw
the wall slapped back at an angle of
about 35 degrees on these are Cheers of
monies each one occupying a separate
Hume Shelf at the head of each is a
small bench on which is found copper
cups and pieces of broken swords some of
the mummies are covered with clay and
all are wrapped in a bark fabric the
urns or cups on the lower tiers are
crude while as the higher shelves are
reached the urns are finer in design
showing a later stage of civilization it
is worthy of note that all the mummies
examined so far have proved to be male
no children or females being buried here
this leads to the belief that this
exterior section was the Warriors
Barracks Kincaid Jordan and the
Smithsonian team explored the entire
cave complex they were overwhelmed with
evidence that this was not some Far Away
Temple occupied by a few priests this
was a huge City lived in by thousands of
men women and children for hundreds or
possibly thousands of years the question
nobody could answer was who were they
by the end of the Expedition GE Kincaid
and Professor Jordan's team had
discovered hundreds of rooms Barracks
granaries metal working shops temples
and many many living quarters though
most of the rooms were empty thousands
of artifacts were found they found
swords and shields made of copper bronze
and a gray medal that scientists
couldn't identify they thought it looked
like Platinum they found Pottery urns
utensils for cooking small yellow stones
called Cat's eyes and large stone
tablets all engraved with hieroglyphics
on all the urns or walls over doorways
and tablets of stone which were found by
the image are the mysterious
hieroglyphics the key to which the
Smithsonian Institute hopes yet to
discover the engraving on the tablets
probably has something to do with the
religion of the people similar
hieroglyphics have been found in
Southern Arizona among the pitorial
writings only two animals are found one
is of prehistoric type even with all the
relics and all the writing Kincaid and
Jordan found they were still no closer
to determining who built the Citadel in
the Grand Canyon they thought some of
the statues looked Tibetan but they
weren't quite right they thought the
writing looked Egyptian again that
wasn't quite right there were experts on
site none of whom could identify the
statues or translate any of the text but
there were two things that the
researchers could agree on one the
civilization that built the Citadel was
very Advanced far more advanced than the
native tribes that occupied the area for
a few thousand years this now Lost
Civilization worked bronze many years
before the Bronze Age began they
understood division of labor and
agriculture when every other Society on
Earth was presumably still hunting and
Gathering these are discoveries that
went against everything that was taught
in mainstream archeology and
anthropology a civilization like this
shouldn't exist what was the second
thing what well you said the Eggheads
agreed on two things what was the second
thing right they agreed that the
civilization that built the Citadel in
the Grand Canyon didn't emerge there
locally this civilization arrived there
from the other side of the world
Kincaid and Professor Jordan sent boxes
of artifacts and books full of notes and
drawings back to the Smithsonian along
with their hypothesis that an ancient
civilization existed in the Grand Canyon
thousands of years before Native
Americans arrived in North America these
people were technologically advanced
educated skilled and spiritually complex
and these people originated somehow in
Egypt or Asia Kincaid wanted more
resources and a larger team to help them
research the Citadel and search the
Grand Canyon for more evidence of this
Lost Civilization the request was denied
and GE Kincaid and Professor essay
Jordan were never heard from again
[Music]
in northern Arizona is one of the most
spectacular natural wonders on Earth the
Grand Canyon carved over millions of
years by the Colorado River the Grand
Canyon is more than just a pretty
landscape and a spot for tourists to
take selfies it's a place of deep
spiritual significance for the people
who've lived in the area the Hopi Navajo
Zuni Apache and several other tribes
have lived around the Grand Canyon for
several thousand years they still do
Hopi mythology says that from the Grand
Canyon the first people of the world
entered the story says that many
thousands of years ago a reptilian race
emerged
yep hey how many times do lizard people
have to come up in these stories before
you believe in him I I guess I'm gonna
need a few more lizard people are gonna
keep popping up you'll see thousands of
years ago a reptilian race lizard people
lizard people emerge from the Grand
Canyon and changed into humans lizard
people are shape-shifters that would
seem to be true other Pueblo cultures
like the Zuni and the Acoma have similar
legends that there were people there
before the tribes lizard people Legends
well some Legends say reptilians were
there other Legends say a race of giants
were there and there are rumors that
skeletons of Giants have been discovered
all over the western United States but
the evidence has been suppressed you're
suppressed by you the Smithsonian of
course something I've learned from doing
the show is that all myths and legends
do carry a little bit of Truth we
already have evidence that people landed
in North America before Columbus the
Vikings famously explored and settled
parts of Newfoundland 500 years before
the quote-unquote new world was quote
unquote discovered and there's growing
evidence that ancient Chinese explorers
landed in North and South America before
the Vikings but landing on the east or
west coast of America is one thing
getting to the Grand Canyon is a whole
other thing how could people get there
and even if they could how did they have
the technology to excavate millions of
tons of rock in order to build an entire
underground city well we may have known
the answer to that question for a
thousand years
traveling from Europe and Asia to
America thousands of years ago was
almost impossible almost many brave
people did it but traveling to the Grand
Canyon is a much more difficult task
than landing on a California beach to
get to and build in the Grand Canyon
requires technology the Hopi have a very
intriguing legend about the ant people
these are humanoid creatures that are
smaller than humans with pale skin and
large eyes like an insect aliens
according to Legend a series of
cataclysms hit the earth many thousands
of years ago young adrias the Hopi were
on the verge of being destroyed a sky
God emerged from what they called a
moving star UFO the sky God brought the
Hopi to the ant people who escorted them
to underground caves for protection the
sky God then got back into his moving
star and flew off above the clouds the
PO'd have a legend about the have
mussoos they're usually described as
being humanoid in shape with golden skin
and large eyes aliens they lived in a
vast underground city and traded with
Far Away people they possessed weapons
that the Pew described as silver tubes
that shot lightning and can kill a man
instantly bases and the most interesting
part of the havmusive legend they
supposedly flew silver canoes in the sky
UFOs these craft made a humming sound
and could maneuver like an eagle and
move at Great speeds most ancient
cultures have a flood myth they describe
a global disaster that melted the ice
caps and caused sea level to rise 400
feet entire cities were wiped out maybe
even entire continents Atlantis most of
these flood myths also talk about how
after the waters receded a god-like
people came down from the sky these Gods
gave humans the gift of civilization and
taught them things they had forgotten
before the great flood things like
writing astronomy and agriculture could
the city in the Grand Canyon be evidence
of this time in history and if it is why
would anyone want to suppress it
all the information in today's episode
comes from Two Front Page articles from
the Phoenix Gazette published in 1909
and the years since mainstream
researchers have decided that the
Articles were a hoax a fantastic story
designed to sell newspapers in 19th
century clickbait yep the media hasn't
changed much unfortunately that's true
but many people believe the story is
real and the Smithsonian is covering it
up
Smithsonian public relations
I'm here I'm here sorry I was on hold a
long time
um they transferred me to Marion yes
this is Marion okay great my name is AJ
and I'm with the y-files we're a YouTube
channel that covers Mysteries
YouTube the Y files is a channel on
YouTube yes
I wanted to talk to you about an article
that was in the Phoenix Arizona Gazette
in 1909 and they sent me to you I was
hoping to ask you a couple of questions
about that okay let me stop you no one
gives you an artifacts of any kind has
ever been found in North or South
America sounds like you've given that
speech before yeah
it's never been involved in anything
like this in the Grand Canyon or
anywhere so GE Kincaid
who recorded anyone by that name ever
working for the Smithsonian the whole
thing is a hoax yeah that's the
prevailing belief but the Smithsonian
has been accused of covering this up so
yeah
yeah you probably don't want to talk
about Giants or giant skeletons huh
that's the official story Kincaid's cave
is a hoax so no reason to try and find
it nothing to see here even Kincaid
himself wanted to keep people out first
I would impress that the cavern is
nearly inaccessible the entrance is
1486 feet down the sheer Canyon wall it
is located on government land and no
visitor will be allowed there under
penalty of trespass the scientists wish
to work unmolested without fear of
archaeological discoveries being
disturbed by curio or Relic Hunters a
trip there would be fruitless and the
visitor would be sent on his way whether
at the request of the Smithsonian or
just to protect his find it was clear
that Kincaid wanted to dissuade people
from finding the Citadel but even over a
hundred years later that wouldn't stop
people from trying and some of those
people
they say they found it
Jerry wills and his wife Kathy have been
studying the Kincaid cave mystery for
years their approach was find the
original base camp of the Explorers
which would lead them to the cave after
years of research and exploring the area
where GE Kincaid said he found the cave
Jerry and Kathy found a location covered
in artifacts from that time and on the
canyon wall just below this area they
believe is the entrance to the
underground city exploring is difficult
though the entire area where the cave is
supposed to be is designated off limits
by the federal government you guys saw
that coming about a thousand caves have
been discovered in the Grand Canyon many
of them man-made but only about 30 have
been mapped and many of those have been
sealed oh I close them off oh for your
safety but it's a bunch of yeah
I don't buy the safety excuse either
there are plenty of people who'd be
willing to take the risk and they'd be
willing to sign a waiver that says the
government isn't responsible if
something happens in fact people have
tried this the government still says no
it's too dangerous how nice did a
government to look out for us isn't that
nice then why is it legal to jump out of
a plane or ride a roller coaster or
drive a car some things in life are
dangerous but they're still worth doing
some other caves in the Grand Canyon
have been blocked by Steel Gates they
say this is to protect the bat
population did you say bats we have to
protect the bats that's what they say
we're having bats caused enough problems
these last few years allegedly
still people are willing to risk a fine
or imprisonment to find the lost city in
the Grand Canyon but anyone who goes
looking should expect a response when
Jerry and Kathy's team tried to explore
the area suddenly an unmarked plane
appeared clearly they were being watched
despite this part of the Grand Canyon
being a no-fly zone and the fact that no
aircraft is allowed to fly below the rim
a plane appeared Jerry Wills is
convinced this was a warning his team
was unable to continue their expedition
exploring the cave from above is almost
impossible but what about exploring it
from below as GE Kincaid did another
group of explorers tried this as they
approached the location a black
helicopter showed up not a tourist
helicopter not even a black civilian
helicopter an Apache combat helicopter
when this team explored the area above
looking for the ventilation shafts
Kincaid wrote about and possibly a way
down they found cement blocks in the
middle of nowhere some of these blocks
are platforms near the edge of the rim
with hardware and anchors that would be
used to assist Mountaineers when asked
about this the authorities say these are
reinforcing structures to prevent rock
falls also in this forbidden zone rock
formations have unusual names there is
Isis Temple Tower of set Horus the kiops
pyramid and raw there's also the Manu
Temple the Buddha temple the Krishna
Temple and the Sheba Temple and many
more names that refer to ancient
Egyptian and Hindu cultures cultures
that specifically have myths about a God
helping civilization after the great
flood the official word is the fact that
these names exist within the grand
Canyon's no-go zone is a coincidence but
I don't really believe in those do you
[Music]
David Hatcher Childress is a French
author who's published 200 books he
often covers ancient Mysteries he
believes the United States government is
actively suppressing archaeological
discoveries he mentions that while the
film Raiders of the Lost Ark is fiction
the final scene showing the warehouses
close to reality that the Smithsonian
and independent Federal agency is hiding
some of the most important discoveries
made in the Americas he says the
cover-up began in 1881 with famous
geologist John Wesley Powell Powell
appointed Cyrus Thomas the director of
the Eastern Mound division of the
Smithsonian institutions Bureau of
ethnology when Thomas came to the
Smithsonian he believed there was a race
of mound builders that were distinct
from and arrived before the American
Indians this school of thought is called
diffusionism which says throughout
history there's been a widespread
dispersion of culture and civilization
even across great distances the
Smithsonian took the opposite approach
it promoted isolationism which says most
civilization nations are isolated from
each other and have little contact
especially when separated by large
bodies of water it was held at the
advanced and highly populated
civilizations of the Ohio and
Mississippi valleys were rare and that
they didn't have contact with other
Advanced cultures like the Aztecs the
toltecs or the Maya but the Mississippi
river runs from Canada all the way to
the Gulf of Mexico to say these cultures
were isolated is like saying that people
in the Black Sea had no contact with
people in the Mediterranean that's
ridiculous when ancient mounds of the
American Midwest are examined they show
the existence of a complex culture
cities larger than those in Europe at
the time they also show burials of
extremely tall people sometimes seven or
eight feet tall when the Spiro Mounds
were excavated in the 1930s seven and
eight foot tall skeletons were found at
a time when the average height of a
human male was about five foot six those
skeletons have been lost in 1892 Stone
coffins were discovered in Alabama by
Frank Burns during a Geological Survey
the coffins were about seven and a half
feet long hollowed out by fire and metal
chisels the findings were sent to the
Smithsonian in 1984 this report was
found by researcher Frederick J pole he
asked the Smithsonian about this they
said we have not been able to find the
specimens in our collections though
records show that they were received oh
how do you giant Stone coffins that
weighed several tons I don't know and
never underestimate the incompetence of
the federal government eight years later
the Smithsonian said they found the
coffins but they were stored in a
warehouse that was contaminated by
asbestos so nobody could go in there to
see him
during World War II a crew was building
an airship in Alaska they excavated a
mound that had gigantic human remains
skeletons twice or three times the size
of a normal human this report has been
confirmed by multiple sources the
Smithsonian collected the findings and
that was the last anyone heard about it
there were stories like this from Alaska
all the way down to Mexico City an
amazing Discovery is made the
Smithsonian steps in the story
disappears the saying skeletons in your
closet means you have secrets you don't
want revealed secrets that if discovered
would be embarrassing and possibly
dangerous in the case of the Smithsonian
skeletons in the closet could be taken
literally but the government literally
has evidence that an advanced race was
in North America long before the native
tribes arrived evidence they don't want
revealed mainstream science says this is
nonsense but the Hopi and other Grand
Canyon tribes do believe this the Hopi
say that when the first people emerged
from the Grand Canyon they sent a
message to the temple of son asking for
a blessing of peace that messenger
hasn't returned but even today in Hopi
Villages at sundown tribal Elders can be
seen on rooftops gazing toward the
Setting Sun waiting for the messenger to
come home and when he does the ancient
land will be returned to the first
people now that's an optimistic belief
the United States spent 200 years taking
Land from the first people
you really think they're going to give
it back
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps the channel and like
most topics we cover here today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips and special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible without our patreon
members there would be no wi files if
you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon or
grabbing something from the Wi-Fi store
I know inflation is making everyone Jack
their prices but we have
nots up there yet not yet we'll get
cracking sport they are definitely
watching us I'm working on it that's
gonna do it until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
thank you